onder's asks how do you keep aim on your
goals and separate yourself from the
demands of the external world Andre I'll
take this one first uh you know I don't
know what to tell you other than it's
unbelievable for me how much the
external world has not factored into my
decision making I've talked about if
you've been watching a show long enough
that first F on a on a test in fourth
grade and literally making that
transition to I'm gonna fight the market
and I've been fighting the market my
whole life I think for me it was the
level of self-esteem that my mom
instilled in me plus some level of my
own DNA I think that's the friction at
hand heck a lot of the themes of our
last question we're on this right like
what does the market want you to do
whether that's your parents or society
versus what you want to do for me it has
a lot to do with intestinal fortitude a
Gorilla Monsoon WWF reference uh you
know I think I think its surrounding
yourself with people that give you
permission to take that risk that to me
is the most practical version of what
I'm giving you other than you got to be
born with it it's finding those
like-minded people who are who are
taking those similar risks and and give
you through their own actions a little
more um or if you're amazingly lucky to
have that parental or mentor
infrastructure above you that created
that context okay so I think focus is
everything I think that you can do ten
things poorly or one thing well and say
no is something that I only learned late
in my career don't suck at it I still
suck at it right now
say no is so hard but the truth is like
we're surrounded by leeches blood
suckers and vampires and those are
people that want to take take take and
they don't give back and learning to say
no to those people learning to say no to
all those distractions is the only way
to get anywhere because time is finite
life is short quickly you find things
that are in life that are really
incredible like family things that you
love things that you're passionate about
that might that might distract you in a
positive way from from your career focus
so you have to learn to shed everything
else I'm going to throw a little bit of
a curveball I
I get so much happiness out of doing
things for people who would be cool you
know categorize as the way you just
broke it down because I have a weird
gear inside of me that has zero
expectation for the return on someone's
selfishness I know that's a little bit
of a mouthful but it's just it's
probably why I'm so ridiculously happy
I'm I have such little expectation for
the return it makes me happy to do the
give I sit in front of you knowing I
will accomplish less in my career and
amass less wealth and a lot of other
things less time with my family which is
my number one because I get so much
happiness out of some of those actions
so I would tell you if you're in a rare
group like myself make sure you
recognize in a world where people tell
you that you're a sucker for doing and
things of that nature
you still got to make yourself happy but
I will tell you I'm Way happier than I
was five years ago because I have grown
in my no meter moving a ton hasn't got a
zero and I think a lot of people close
themselves out of serendipity by saying
no too much right and I think we
probably both benefited through our
years of of the yes when it didn't make
sense on paper but I'm with you man then
I mean I made a video a long time ago
the yes virus it's like the sickness of
just saying yes all the time and it's a
tough one yeah big movies everybody's
just say yes like I believe in saying
yes I believe in embracing risk and
embracing chance and all you say no more
as you get older I just think it's it's
a learning curve a very steep learning
curve to understand when note was
appropriate one yes is appropriate and
until you learn that you default to yes
it's a really really or know my dad
defaults to no I think you and I like we
have some similarities that makes like I
think there's a lot of people there that
default to no I think there's a lot of
people at default my dad's opening words
and hate that no like I care I was gonna
say how was your day
you know like knows not appropriate like
I know a lot of people that default into
no I think we happen to be surrounded by
a lot of people that default into yes
yes but I think you know being you know
what actually quick little side question
of the day give me a are you a default
yes or no person I'm just curious for
my own kind of like polling India move
it along